so for a long time people have
speculated and for many years they've
gotten it wrong saying that trump would
have been richer if he had just invested
his inheritance into the s p 500 and not
bothered with any of the real estate
stuff that he's been up to for the last
several decades and for a long time that
wasn't true he actually had outperformed
the market
debt and a couple of smart deals and a
couple of lucky deals meant that he'd
done better than the s p 500 but all
that changed in the middle of the
pandemic so we currently estimate that
donald trump is worth two and a half
billion dollars if he had done nothing
other than just take his father's money
and put it all in the s p 500 and watch
it grow for decades he would now be
worth about 2.9 billion dollars so he'd
be 400 million dollars richer than he is
today
in order to know whether trump has
outperformed or underperformed the s p
500 over his life you have to be able to
answer three questions the first is how
much money did he receive from his
father the second is when did he get
that money and the third is what's he
actually worth and for a long time no
one could answer the first two of those
questions but a few years ago we got
that information answered in a story by
the new york times where they explained
that as of october 2nd 2018
if trump had invested his father's money
into the s p 500 he would have been
worth 1.96 billion dollars what we can
do is then take that number and then
move it as the s p 500 has moved over
time and compare it to trump's net worth
so we now have a day-by-day calculation
that we can do saying
did trump make more money making the
investments that he made or would he
have been richer if he just sat back
lived a quiet life and stuck it all in
the s p 500
so the real estate market has changed a
lot during the pandemic all across the
country and in most places it's done
pretty well but one place that it hasn't
done as well is in manhattan in new york
city and that's where donald trump's
holdings are focused so if you think
about what he owns you know a lot of
office space in a big city and also a
lot of storefronts in a big city people
weren't going to those storefronts
anymore they were buying things on
amazon that means that future tenants
are going to be less likely to want to
pay huge rents to the owner of that
building donald trump
for
companies that are looking to lease
office space they might not need as much
office space anymore that means that
they
are going to be leasing less it's just a
supply and demand thing therefore the
office space that is currently built
will be worth less so both of those two
factors have hurt donald trump's net
worth during the pandemic in addition to
that you also have residential real
estate that he owns in new york city and
unlike a lot of other markets new york
city residential real estate hasn't held
up nearly as well comparing donald
trump's performance to the s p 500 is
admittedly a very nerdy thing to do and
it's just an academic exercise
you have to understand that by living
the life that he did live
he not only got to have a lot of fun
building a lot of buildings and uh
having fun in atlantic city sometimes
not so much fun in atlantic city doing
all sorts of things going on the
apprentice
buying yachts
buying the plaza hotel all this crazy
stuff all of which donald trump has
loved he's loved doing all these
business ventures he's loved being a
famous person
there's no way that he would have been
president if he hadn't done what he did
if he hadn't done all those business
ventures if he just stuck his
inheritance into the s p 500 sat back
and done nothing nobody would even know
who donald trump is instead what he's
left with is this really exciting life
but ultimately he's 400 million dollars
poorer than he would be if he'd just
taken it the easy way